this is our thoughts on the Jungle Book
hey yeah Rob what I have no idea what's
going on at all oh this is Chris a lot
of you may know him from cinemasins and
he just happened to be in town and Rob
can make the movie tonight so he stepped
in and I say once he jungle book he said
hell yeah that's right yeah that's right
so excited um and I also can't find our
usual cameras of the sound sounds
weirder this looks weird that's why um
so but you don't need that kind of great
sound or video quality for this uh it's
uh it's well it's the jungle book and I
guess before we talk about what we think
about it um we should probably set up
like just our thoughts on the jungle
book in general like just the the
previous movies and book and stuff like
that I I'm a huge fan of the book like
love the book um I think it's like a
masterpiece it's a classic it's
wonderful the cartoon movie that Disney
anime movie I think is okay you know it
which gets a lot of people think I hate
it I really don't it's fine it's not the
book but it's fine it's a cute little
movie um and and of course there's what
the 1993 cleanses is the rector of The
Mummy
yeah and Jason Scott Lee yeah the
titular well not yeah what I'm clearly
the best version um vods i yeah that was
pretty stupid yeah um but I won't worry
your thoughts on the cartoon um I mean I
like the cartoon it's not something that
I go back to and watch all the time or
anything I haven't read the book but
from what you've described the book
sounds awesome yeah and I love the Chuck
Jones animated short on the bugger it is
very good thumbs
strangely enough the most faithful
adaptation so far um which brings us to
this movie and what's it now 94% knows
yeah yeah
and uh you know if you're looking to
just drop off your kid for an hour and a
half and just shown something harmless
got a few thrills and you know some cute
animals it's fine if you want ever good
jungle book movie this sucks
94% you're only hurting yourself yeah
critics I mean what am I missing it when
we were done I like I'm just sitting
here near of us had that much interest
in seeing and you know but it's like but
94% Jesus it's insane it's like it's
like it's supposed to be the good
fellows yeah so I'm like wow okay maybe
they maybe they got the good adaptation
I mean okay they can't do the full book
I know but maybe they combine the two
and it really really worked out and when
I was done I just look to him like did
you like this yeah main problem for me
is there's no real connection to the
characters none the whole main reason
for this story to go on and everything
for for Mowgli to go back to the to the
place where he was raised and everything
is the death of the character that I
didn't care about yeah and you barely
see and so obviously there's going to be
some changes from uh you know from the
cartoon and from the the bark which is
fine nothing is better nothing is better
than the anime film nothing is better
than the book so I had no idea why this
existed yeah even with that Cinderella
remake that definitely have problems
it's like some stuff I'm like no but
that's better than the anime movie you
know that the prince was more developed
it was visually interesting they try to
change some things up that he'll be on
other things weren't so it's like I get
it I get why to retell it with this I
mean a you have a phenomenal story just
given to you on a silver platter with
the book and even if not I mean the
story you're trying to tell if I didn't
know the jungle bug like the animated
movie or the book or anything like I
wouldn't have a connection to anybody
yeah this boy you don't even see how
they find Mowgli until like what the
halfway point yeah he's just running
through the woods
Bagheera comes they
that stupid thing like from the early
90s where it's like oh no he's being
chased all they were just playing it's
that kind of movie that's like 30 years
old yeah that that trick yeah um and you
know you see it coming a mile away but
it's like okay maybe it gets better but
it's like this kid you know you just
start off
he's with these walls and you just
accept it and you know you don't find
out where he came from until halfway
with a cognate eise's him to remember
strange thing to do to your food yeah
yeah which of course leads to the day's
ex machina of loot you know blue showing
up ah where because instead of just
killing him you know it's like well it's
wait long enough for somebody to come
and save you not good enough why the
hell doesn't that bear eat more yeah
yeah right leave them and okay that's a
huge problem there is no reason for
these animals to like Mowgli in both the
book and the cartoon they show them have
a connection they show him as a baby and
it's one of those things where it's just
he's so helpless and he's so strange and
he's so not gonna harm anyone they're
curious by it and they're intrigued
there's none of that he's not even a
baby he's like a toddler yeah the one he
comes to him and he's just walking
through the woods and Bagheera is like
oh there's somebody I'd like to bring
back to the to the place where I live
apparently Bagheera raised him know
there's a wolf mother yeah yeah none of
that makes sense right um of course I'm
gonna be the cynical one here I mean and
you're gonna you're gonna follow along
because you know you're gonna computer
play along because you're going to know
exactly where I'm going the reason why
we keep seeing these movies is because
Disney has a huge roster of animated
movies that they want to repurpose to a
younger generation over and over and
over again we will see one day probably
a little mermaid like this yes
you know live-action will see Lion King
live-action
someday I think we did have the season s
movie up remind o release chasing you
know like you know at the end to see you
know you see a feel I'm falling into a
pit of fire I'm like oh no no um I also
I hate those little precious terms that
they give like you know the red flower
or whatever like they know all these
English terms and everything but they're
like a fire it's the red flower you know
well the funny thing again it cuz I did
something else from the book but the
book definitely has this sense of like
you know they call them the man-cub you
know it's like they don't have boy they
have man-cub Caesar get like they had
this language but you get why they would
name it this thing if you saw a fire I
mean they would be a but you haven't
even tried to sort complicate that too
because they're like both these like do
you have a language to like something
they're a monkey or something which even
then King Louie has a language but the
rest of the monkeys don't they're just
chilling god they just happen to speak
the same language as the walls yeah you
know um and you haven't even gotten to
the cowbell yet yes oh my god so so
Chris we're walking is King Louie in
this as a live you know surprisingly
doing an okay job I'm actually like I'm
kind of buying this this is actually
okay and then there's two are you
fucking kidding me moments I mean just
huge are you fucking kidding me but one
is that as soon as the kid goes into
this temple there's all these little
treasures one of them is a cowbell he
picks up the cowbell rings it and that
Salman King that happened in the bad but
no but even that's not the weirdest
fucking thing so okay so this movie
there's no it's not a musical
there's no songs the most is that blues
like oh the don't you ever say I'm the
song the bare necessities that's just a
little song they hum to each other it's
fine it's like if we do ever hear this
song yeah Chris or Walken is King Louie
out of nowhere he's talking these these
really aggressive a story I want the red
flower don't you see don't you see I
wanna be like you
I'm gonna walk like you talk like you
true and it's like let's go bro what the
hell is going on cuz he was like this
actually kind of intimidating presence
yeah like this big dark thing and the
shadows and even the face kind of looks
like walking right as these eyes and
it's like you know it's like I I could
squash you if I wanted and he sings this
dumb ass oh yeah and then of course he's
chasing after Mowgli and he's like you
know what I can smash this temple down
yeah do that I didn't understand that
either yeah he destroys his home yeah
presumably died yeah yeah you know
replicated by the rocks yes
so okay so um I'll try to think of
there's like sheer kind of makes no
sense to yes you're right cuz again in
you can tell they're trying to combine
the book and the movie which is like you
know a noble idea I kids like you know
you want to try to combine the two to
get these to us sometimes they'll have a
line from the book like the law of the
jungle the red flower and stuff like
that but there's all these things where
it's like the anime jungle book which I
now have this phenomenal appreciation
for much more than I ever did uh it was
kind of doing its own thing and it's
different from the book and that's fine
it's not gonna be the book but it's
charming it's cute it's got a good
characters you know and Shere Khan is
intimidating and you get why he's
chasing Mowgli's like he likes the hunt
and he hates man you know he just he
won't listen to reason Jesse's man's
like I want to get that I want to you
know he's just got all this power in the
book he's he's his thug he's also he's
like Suge Knight ya know it's like he's
got intelligence but he's mostly a thug
yeah and he slowly manipulates them over
time uh you know to get this man come
because he's not going to the man
village he he stay so he's slowly
manipulating everybody to his side over
time and it's just so smart and you know
cuz he's afraid way he's gonna crumble
he's gonna become and he's also you know
like in this he's killed the family so
he wants to get him as well so it makes
sense here they're trying to combine the
two the trying to
can sophisticated and charming but also
this brute so the plan makes yeah well
I'm not right like how does this Tiger
go into a den of wolves and a lot of
other like dangerous scary animals and
just says I'm gonna rule this place just
because I said so I'm Jagger you know
that's pretty much what it is and I
never understood that like if you're a
bunch of wolves you're not gonna let a
tiger come in and be like I'm gonna tell
you what's what
yeah he's holding the wolves hostage
it's just what yeah and he's like you
know but he's gone he's out of here what
do you care I want him dead
he's like why Mowgli's gonna hear this
story and he's gonna come back like his
whole plan is predicated on mowgli
hearing this yeah later somehow and he
does both somehow Bagheera gets knocked
out says fuck Mowgli no go back to the
wolf sees what's going on there oh maybe
I should go after Mowgli again this all
happens off screen cuz he knows about
the death of a Caleb who's like they'll
even make it clear if it's his father or
just the ruler of the pack or whatever
um and and then yet King Louie somehow
you know yeah he's got ears all over the
forest but like like who in that it
would have had to been somebody at his
original village who came out like maybe
it was like insects or something we
don't talk to the monkey yeah they don't
think that the same way
yeah it's a it's one of those movies
were it basically relies on you to think
back on your nostalgia to understand
everything like oh well I know this
story so like everything in here that
doesn't make sense well I'll just fill
in the gaps with all the my nostalgia
and everything it remind me a little bit
of maybe a strange comparison I don't
know it reminds me a bit of Batman vs
Superman it's like here's these things
that you recognize but they're not in
here for the right reasons
we're not putting it in with the
character behind it with the purpose
behind it we're just putting it because
you recognize it and it's a mix of both
the enemy movie and the book but they're
just they're missing the importance of
both because with the exception of maybe
Bill Murray gets a few well yeah you
no I mean but I'd still probably one say
I you know would like him more than like
the animated blue I mean you know him
and the boy in that had a much bigger
connection this one they know each other
less than a day and he's doing this
stupid kid I hear I don't want to see
him I wasn't ever your friend and then
like Moga runs away oh god what have I
done it needed to be done blue now let
him climb that tree and mope and leggy
kidnap we'll just stay down here yeah
there's some reason and then he's like
oh hey think have that kid I will I'll
never forgive myself I'll never end it's
just you feel no connection between
these two yeah and it's uh and I feel
like the whole finale is too long to the
you know the you know the the like it
makes no sense at all kids I think it's
okay to give this away a little bit I
mean we won't go into too much detail
but he gets this torch he gets the fire
accidentally sets the jungle on fuck
yeah yeah well yeah just want these
little sparks falling from the storage
it's like okay it's even had like a
lingering shot of him running and it
like seeing the start of the fire I feel
like a spark fall agency on the ground
like that's it you don't see anything
flickering or anything and it's just
like he comes with this fire to fight
your card and he's like you know oh they
don't fear me they fear you know turn
around
Oh fire what twice Penta that happen and
somehow someway during the battle at the
end nobody gangs up on Shere Khan it's
always one-on-one battle its first let's
let's have blue do it and then oh let's
have one of the Wolves do it and then a
Bagheera will do it and then and then
it's like oh really just a set up this
whole Mowgli goes into the woods and
traps you no traps the tiger oh yeah so
it's like it's something where it's like
if both the both am a film in the book
were very they're very clear in their
worlds and they were just like you know
the the Emmy film didn't have as much
structure but it's it's fine it's the
jungle it's a road trip you're coming
these creatures and stuff the book had a
lot of structure uh you know and they
followed it you know very hardcore I
mean like the law of the jungle they go
into great detail what the law of the
jungle is why it is that's why at first
I thought maybe they were doing it
because they're doing this weird thing
about peace rock and stuff that was
really confusing but I'm like okay let's
kind of see where they're going with it
and it's like yeah just all the rules
and laws they just kind of check out the
window cuz this dumbass tiger is like no
ma ya watch my house I got the
motivation Lex Luthor from Batman vs
Superman
I'm just dick ya makes no separate um
and yeah god yeah so was there anything
good about this movie I would say
visually it looks pretty good I I still
think the CGI and this get took me out
of it a little bit a few times it's I
was very impressed how much it you you
are right there's several times where
it's like okay well that's fake good are
there those are that I was very
impressed how many times I was taking it
seriously though and almost believing
they were there and what like with Balu
especially yeah very legitimately and
there's a scene where Mowgli who by the
way this actor this kid actor is pretty
good to probably have been enough room
nothing but green sky the whole time
interacting with you know just people
yelling at him probably and stuff like
that but there is a scene with him
touching the wolf's his mom yeah
everyone looks like he's touching yeah
it's really good um and Bill Murray is
gonna like I said has some laughs yeah I
can't think of any performances there
like quote-unquote bad but you know
Scarlett Johansson is cop yeah lawyers
right yeah yeah i I mean it just seemed
like you know it's like okay she does
fine and she looks kind of cool but it's
like all those Scarlett Johansson's
Kyle's Christopher Walken is King Louie
those bill Maria's balloon yeah it's
basically it's basically where the
Simpson started going where it was like
look at all these guest stars that we
got to be our you know in our cartoon
they're playing themselves isn't that
great you know
oh yeah I think it's a good I think you
nailed it that's not characters you're
seeing guest stars mm-hmm um and they're
fine I mean there's not like anything
super distracting they're just you don't
make a connection with them yeah and I
think that's you know where I think the
book really had story and the anime film
had character you know that that's the
this one has neither and is trying to
combine these two and it's missing what
elements should have been at the center
what should have been the most important
and yeah I don't get I don't get 94%
either it I feel the same way I did
about Cinderella when it came out it
just did yeah cuz I got like a ton of
great huge rage reviews and then at
least I can understand a touch more
brightly like say at least there's some
things that were better than the
original yeah and different even you
know they're like oh that this was
better but it's like nothing here seemed
like I can't see anyone watching us be
like oh god that was so much better than
the end I was so much better than the
book right it's about time this came out
you know this is really necessary to our
you know our existence yeah maybe comes
up I don't get what it furthered I
really don't get what this light brought
to us that we didn't see before that
just you like you said needed to be
discovered and like us as a fan of the
book it pisses me off because there is
something you can discover an anti
circuses making this movie right now
he's making a film that's gonna stick
closer to the book and I'm really not
one of those people I goes nuts about
like it's different from the source
material it's like it's fine if it works
you know the enemy of film did work um
and this one just doesn't yeah and it's
a shame cuz there's this wonderful story
right there waiting to be used and maybe
circus will bring it to the limelight
but it's it's a shame um or maybe it's
not you know because maybe I think maybe
we do need to step away from the Disney
Jungle Book
Obed two-e-and on so we can get this
different one and maybe Andy Serkis is
one good sock oh yeah good it could be
awful but yeah it's just I think it's
more because the technology on some of
these creatures like Baloo
with sometimes Bagheera and stuff you
know does I are you even more than half
the time looks really legitimately
impressive it's a shame it's like oh we
can't get that in something that really
deserves it we're just gonna sort do
this very very half-ass script I think
that's the biggest room uh you know even
the boy there's times where I'm like
well why have the boys say that why
would he do this why would he but it's
like it's it's not his fault I mean it's
just not a good script you know and yes
a little work with and like you said
when you're mostly looking at bright
tennis balls ah it's have you got a damn
good job right oddly enough though
coming out of this tonight the thing I'm
coming out with is I'm actually
interested in this Andy Serkis version
so I haven't seen a thing about it as
soon as I heard there's an Andy Serkis
movie being directed by him it's gonna
be closer to the book I'm just I am so
excited the first time I heard about
this I was like really there's another
chuggabug this is terrible but when you
when you told me about the book and you
obviously have passion about it and
everything and that he's following it
and everything I actually want to see it
yeah um what if you want good build-up
for it uh you and the people watching at
home go see the Chuck Jones animated
show I think it's called Mowgli's
projects that's actually the original
name of the story the jungle book is
actually a collection of stories um and
it has no budget you know and it's
clearly repeated animation and it's only
one voice actor doing the whole thing
but the voice actor is Robbie McDowell
yeah and easy that's a powerhouse actor
and you know it's just it's Chuck Jones
that's a powerhouse animator and it's
who you are Kipling a powerhouse writer
and it's just like you know it can be
cheap but it's like good god it just it
sticks with you yeah and that's just
something I don't think anyone that sees
this film it's not gonna stick with
anyone no it really isn't it's gonna be
forgotten about you know a year later
yeah I think my people can watch it and
enjoy it fine like I said I mean there's
nothing and Savannah and I don't think
it's too scary for kids or anything like
no it does it does that I did hear some
gasps in this auditorium a little bit a
few a few times although
I mean it does it does try to get to
that like shutting the surprise I got
access yeah there's nothing to boos yeah
and then for the most part they're
pretty well laid out that's another
thing that was another thing about that
akira death or whatever it's like it's
like I don't know this character very
well and then it like sheer Khan kills
them and it's like well then he die or
did he not yeah yeah so anyway um but
yeah it's uh that's our thoughts on it
like I said I don't think it is it like
our worst movie embarrassing no it's
just something where it's like I really
love the source material it's to me what
I think to a lot of you people like
Batman vs Superman was like this is the
under we're gonna see my death of
Superman you know the movie you know
it's like I'm never gonna take my
chugalug movie but maybe I will I don't
know hey um so but no it's not the worst
thing ever it's just very forgettable
very unnecessary to do it this way and
uh yeah but if you want just go and I'll
see Kapoor bears and Bill Murray talking
and you know if you will runs and jumps
me I mean yeah okay but yeah I be able
to get four jungle boat now yeah no
nothing that official from Djokovic he
is here yeah um so yeah guys that's
about it and I I at least the we'll see
you later okay